How do we express '15 by 20' as a percentage?
We know that if we have to express something as a percentage
we have to make its 'denominator equal to 100'.
So '15 by 20'
should equal some number 'x by hundred'.
To find the percentage we just have to find out what this 'x' is.
These are actually two equal ratios,
which means this is proportion.
Since this is proportion
'15 multiplied by 100'
is equal to '20 multiplied by x'.
The product of the extremes
is always equal to the product of the means.
Transposing 20 to the other side
we write 'x' as '15 multiplied by 100' 'divided by 20'.
'100 divided by 20' is '5'.
And hence, 'x' is equal to '15 multiplied by 5'
which equals '75'.
Hence '15 by 20 is 75 by 100'.
And that is equivalent to '75 percent'.
This was the concept of how we converted into percentage form.
But notice what we did.
All we did was multiply the fraction by hundred.
Can we do this every time?
Yes, to convert a fraction to percentage terms,
we just have to 'multiply it by 100'.
All this was done
just so that you can understand
why we multiply the fraction by 100.
It's because we want the denominator to be hundred,
and since these are equivalent ratios,
we multiply '15 by 20' by '100'.
Let's express '3 by 5' as a percentage.
We 'multiply 3 by 5' by '100'.
'5 times 20' is '100'.
And '20 times 3' is '60'.
That gives us '60'.
So '3 by 5 is equal to 60 percent'.
Remember, to convert a fraction to percentage
just multiply the fraction by 100.
This formula will help you solve problems really quick.